the European Union's competitiveness
councils adopted a common approach on
new rules to better protect trade
secrets which are vital to business
innovation and underpinned fair
competition he aims to make it easier
for national courts to deal with the
problem and for victims to be
compensated as well as remove products
that infringe on trade secrets from the
market survey suggests that one in five
businesses has been the target of
attempted theft of trade secrets in the
EU in the last decade and the phenomenon
is on the rise the agreement paves the
way for negotiations on the rules to
begin with the European Parliament the
adoption of this directive once the
European Parliament reached an agreement
at first reading will be an important
step forward in the e use innovation
policy as adequate protection of trade
secret is an important enabler of
innovation ministers also adopted a
position on technical requirements for
new cars to be fitted with an emergency
call system for use in accident
throughout Europe known as equal the
council agreed in early May to deploy
the eu-wide system which would consist
of a wireless device that manufacturers
fit to cars and which would trigger a
call to the 112 emergency number it's
hoped that he call can speed up the
emergency response to road accidents and
bring down casualty numbers as the Union
looks to half traffic deaths by the year
twenty twenty